in Game two on Sunday night but they are  going to put those up with coach bud  scripted that first play in practices  executed beautifully after a little bit  of a breakdown initiative tiling the  ball in situation you're asking for  trouble  good job by Malcolm of understanding and  recognizing shrewder in for Paul George  George works around that big screen sent  by Steven Adams right at the top yeah  have you got a way with one eye but he  leaned that a right shoulder and the  snows going down the list is guys these  massive guides inside just pretty much  had their way with buck defenders and  his candor in his inner huge day for the  Knicks Dante D Vincenzo took the  challenge to go one-on-one with Yanis at  Summer League so everybody wants to try  and see what he has nullified the shot  blocking of the well with the contact  before the release Paul George continues  to roll in the opening quarter